all right so by now we've all heard
about it Booga a 16 year old kid won
three million dollars at the Fortnight
World Cup this weekend your friends that
don't even play video games your brother
even your mom is texting you asking
about it but to me as I watch Booga pop
off and with life-changing money before
he even graduated high school I couldn't
help but ask myself who the [ __ ] is this
kid and to me the fact that I even have
to ask is a massive problem
[Music]
this weekend epic games tossed around 30
million dollars of prize money across
three days of sold-out competition there
were celebrities parties headshots and
lifetime supplies of money handed out as
over two million people watched across
YouTube and twitch and to me as someone
who watched it all and has been a pretty
big fan of four-night eSports since the
experiment started I gotta say I was
pretty blown away by the product now I'm
not saying this is perfect after all
it's still battle royale eSports
sometimes things just aren't happening
there's a guy on screen chopping wood or
there's wood panels being flown around
in every direction explosions and it can
be a little hard to follow but we've had
these battle royale issues for ever but
what we didn't have is what I want to
talk to you about today what I saw this
weekend wasn't what I'm used to with
fortnight
it wasn't kids flossing or Tim the time
man taking fall damage or ninja
streaming at Lollapalooza but we got to
see this weekend was the real hardcore
fortnight eSports wants to try and drop
out in an opportune moment wait there's
gonna change yes that actually exists
it's not just dancing and celebrations
there are kids behind those monitors
that are grinding and have been grinding
for the last 10 weeks to put on the show
at this World Cup these are the kids
that are mechanically gods at these
shooters with this game we kind of got
the opposite direction of what we're
used to with eSports if you're talking
about a game like League of Legends or
counter-strike when they first rose to
prominence we became immediately
familiar with the best players but with
fortnight we kind of got the biggest
celebrities first but this weekend we
finally got to see what being great at
fortnight really means in a competitive
sense these kids that you're seeing all
these headlines about they're not for
tonight's celebrities they're the the
simples of Fortman
the fakers of Fort Lee the kinds of
eSports personalities that are
associated with only their skill and how
good they are at the game and from my
perspective it's about time that
we see that important look I know that a
lot of you have not been paying
attention to this game and it's eSports
seed the way I have but over the last
year Epic Games has made some strides to
make the viewing experience a little
more watchable they've added mobility
mechanics like ballers and rifts in
order to make sure players can get
across the map to emphasize as many
engagements as possible this way you get
to see these great players fighting each
other and build battling each other as
often as possible in competitive matches
doctor look boat it might be time soon
it might be time soon booga-booga
smiling he's got the health advantage on
creo does folks it might be time for the
shock wave play Booga could soar up into
the sky
[Applause]
oh my gosh confident flavor fuga they
also added this thing called storm surge
which almost forces players to start
fighting in the middle of the game so
you don't get that kind of 1x1
everyone's kind of staring at each other
experience that early fortnight eSports
was criticized for us so heavily all
right so why don't I give you fortnight
patch notes in this video well to me a
lot of this stuff that they've done has
actually allowed these players to shine
and not only that it allowed the
broadcast to shine it allowed people
like dr. Lupo and courage on camera to
pop off the way that we celebrate
casters and other eSports were doing and
to me once all of that stuff was put
together this weekend kind of seemed
like the 30 million dollar extravaganza
that everyone said it was gonna be and
with all that stuff contained and nicely
packaged into one weekend what I saw was
a real eSports scene a hardcore eSports
scene where the best of vests fight it
out and it's not about celebrity or
twitch viewership and all that is great
don't get me wrong I'm stoked about it
but like I said in the intro the big
problem here is nobody knows who the
[ __ ] any of these players are look this
isn't on them they're grinding they're
playing 12 hours a day to try to be the
best player in the world on the biggest
stage this is on Epic booga qualified
for this tournament on week one of the
qualifying season and I'd maybe heard
his name once since then and then this
weekend he almost doubled the points
total of the second-place player this
guy dominated the tournament he was the
best player by a massive margin and the
fact that I had hardly heard about him
until he raised the World Cup trophy is
a massive failure on epics part and it's
not just Booga there were a hundred
players in that Lobby and even more at
the tournament a real built out eSports
scene the way that we've seen in csgo
for years but when I think about
fortnight eSports when I think about
fortnight in general I think about kids
flossing and news clips and ninja and
all these celebrities which i think is
great
but if you want there to be a difference
between fortnight the cultural phenomena
at fortnight eSports where we're taking
it seriously then I need to know who
these players are I need to watch a
hundred of the best players in the
same Lobby every week to see who comes
out on top
look we've watched for the last year as
celebrities have taken this game and
risen it to a level of popularity with
non-endemic players that we've never
seen from a game before it's time to
focus on the guys that could click on
heads and build the Taj Mahal as soon as
they see you in-game it's time to see
how far this eSports scene can grow if
epic just lets it look we've seen and we
know that epic can build these guys into
superstars once they're millionaires
this weekend the epic announced what to
me it seems like what will be a four
night League One season nine wraps up
and we move into our next season we'll
be debuting the fortnight Championship
Series this will give players a chance
to compete against the best of the best
where every single result matters now
this is just a taste of what's to come
as we also plan on stepping up our
competitive efforts across the board and
that hopefully means a hundred of the
best players in the world going
head-to-head every week to see who comes
out with the victory royale and if that
cannot build stars out of these guys
then there is no hope for this eSports
scene thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]